ben uh last week said that his ball his
arm felt especially live and that
perhaps not throwing all week was
something that he was going to talk to
you about again have you had that
conversation and are you willing to
allow him to
sort of forego throwing at practice a
few days
we did have that conversation i'll
acknowledge it was a very brief one and
uh i'll see him at practice on thursday
i love it
it's it's still not clear whether or not
beverage burger was joking when he said
hey you know i didn't practice last week
let me not practice this week he already
gets wednesdays off yes that's why
tomlin said i'll see him on thursday so
implicit in the response was the idea
that ben's already held to a lesser
standard than everyone else every week
on the injury report for wednesday
roethlisberger ben did not practice
right rest right it's never it's never
injury related it was last week though
with the knees and he was on the covet
19 reserve list but you know it worked
out well but they they still want ben to
practice at least a couple of times a
week chris i mean we we all we all need
to practice no matter how long we've
been doing something and and uh i still
don't know whether or not he was joking
i haven't
had the opportunity to not practice
every week he would take it i i doubt it
i you know i i think he is he's the type
of guy where
you know he might not be the
perfectionist maybe we see out of other
hall of fame type quarterbacks right at
least he doesn't come off that way to me
i don't know about you but it doesn't
seem like he's quite
type a obsessive compulsive maybe like a
brady or a breeze or something like that
now when i worked in new england brady
got wednesdays off too it's very common
you know for those that type of
quarterback or player that that late
into their career
but
big man has a reputation that way a
little bit of being a diva and i do
think he's a guy that's hey he's just
not stressed about it i think he goes
man i was put on earth to throw a
football one thing you just put it in my
hand i'll be ready to go on sunday i
just need to get out here and learn what
we're doing and oh they bring that blitz
and all that throwing no problem i don't
i don't even worry about that i really
feel like that's his attitude you know i
go back to last year when i visited them
at training camp so what are you doing
throwing in the off season i don't throw
in the off season what like i just
couldn't believe that answer still to
this day i still i'm shocked by it
and and that's where he's got a lot in
common with brett favre you know favre
hated yeah all of the the practices he
hated the off-season and and and uh he
wanted to play in the games right and
you've got the other end of the spectrum
where peyton manning loved everything
about it tom brady loves everything
about it wants to be involved in
everything about it every practice every
workout we'll have more workouts beyond
what we're supposed to do let's work out
let's get ready let's work let's do it
let's do it and rothersburg's attitude
is let's go play football it's just
football and there's there's a middle
ground there somewhere maybe where it's
not this all-consuming obsession that
overtakes your life
but i don't know uh brady's got six
rings so
maybe maybe the way to be truly
successful at the highest level is to
let it become an obsession that takes
over your life all right uh quarterback
injuries and the most important one drew
brees getting a second opinion to
determine if he needs to go on into
reserve chris my my assessment tell me
if i'm wrong not that you need an
invitation to do so my assessment when a
player gets a second opinion is he
didn't like the opinion that he got from
the team doctors whatever that opinion
may be no you don't like it 100 i i mean
you don't really
really hear that a lot with nfl football
players i mean you don't because you
know you've talked about it before we've
had this discussion
usually the nfl team in that city has
the best doctor in the city
to be there and be the guy that takes
care of the football team and all that
so you know
listen throwing shoulder ribs all those
things maybe he's being extra careful
but yeah i lean towards more of what
you're saying he didn't like what he was
told what i think is peculiar or mike or
what i would like to know is just did he
not like what he was told in an
aggressive way or in a non-aggressive
way you know what i mean did they tell
him hey we think you need to sit out a
little longer and he went i don't like
that let me go see someone else that
might tell me i'm back quicker or was it
the other way around where he went wait
they're saying i might be able to come
back this week and i don't feel that
normal like there's no way this is
really bothering me maybe i need to see
another doctor that's that's where i'm
i'm interested to know which way we are
there
based on the aggressive way that he was
performing his thumb exercises last year
during his absence my guess is he wants
to get back on the field no matter what
and i think he's desperate at a minimum
to reverse the perception that was
created on sunday that he tapped out and
could have kept going
right and and sean payton did him a
favor by
making it clear look we've been together
15 years the first time this has ever
happened he truly couldn't go
i think that it bugs him at some level
that he was there in uniform
he played the first half he kept playing
after he took that hit
he i i think you know football players
wanted it's hard it's tough it's the
hardest and it's like it's it's it's
it's not about us
it's about the other guys who play
football remember when cam newton was
having his struggles he said yeah you
know you hear from the coaches but also
they look at you differently in the
locker room guys talk i think that
may be influencing drew brees to create
the impression he's trying to get back
as soon as he possibly can and that
maybe the team is saying we need to shut
you down for a few weeks yeah i i would
not be surprised that it is hard
to say
i can't go anymore when you're in the
football uniform
and you know you can run and do some of
those things right but you can't do you
know as far as a quarterback's concerned
the number one thing you need to do to
be a successful quarterback it's hard to
say no to that you know i
i i separated my shoulder actually
against new orleans once and man it was
hurting me so much and i couldn't throw
the ball 10 yards i was this close to
still saying i can go coach i was gonna
just screw the team over and go i can go
it was my first start ever you know but
but i i knew i was like man i can't do
this i can't do this to myself and i
can't do it to the team and then of
course with my spleen incident i wasn't
coming off the field i wasn't tapping
out i could still throw coach i'm
breathing the hell with it let's go it's
hard but drew i can sit here and tell
you nobody has got that perception about
you as tapping out nobody i mean i will
defend you to the day you die and that
one he is tough as hell he wants to be
out there he's got brady breathing down
his neck for all time touchdown pass the
record he doesn't want any of that to no
he doesn't want to lose that there's no
way he doesn't want to play right now so
people are crazy if they question drew
brees toughness that way i'm not saying
they are i'm saying that that's
something that he would be worried i
know no one is questioning his touch i
know i know i think that he's getting
the second opinion because he's got sean
payton and he's got the saints doctors
saying you need to go on into reserve
for three weeks yeah and it's breeze
saying no i want to be carried on the
roster because i think i could be back
in one week and when you look at the
upcoming three games the saints probably
think they can win them without him and
let's let this guy get healed so he's
100 or close to it for the stretch run
right yeah you're you're right and
that's where mike i was going to ask you
do you think like you know again
drew i think is a very self-aware guy he
understands his standing in the history
of football and all those things
i feel like he also would want to he'd
be thinking about man i don't want the
backup to come in again for the second
year in a row and go three and four and
four and oh without me you know it just
it's not a great look even though we all
know there's more to it than one guy or
anything like that but you know people
do look at teddy bridgewater last year
and go they went 5-0 they were still
really good when he was in there and i'm
sure he hates that aspect of it too and
that's what's hard as a competitor you
don't want to
start up those type of conversations
remember back in week one the first
sunday of the season when the saints
were hosting the buccaneers it was brady
versus breeze for the first time in the
same division
four or five different reporters had
some version of the idea that the saints
were interested in brady even after
brees committed to playing again i think
brees knows that at some level of that
organization someone is thinking yeah
the time has come to push him away on an
iceberg and move on right and and
remember when sean payton in the
off-season let it slip that this is
breezed last year yeah and they need to
come back and say oh wait wait a minute
i misspoke
speak misspeak this is last year right
right so
that's part of what he's fighting back
against too and it's all normal it's all
natural it's human when you've been
doing something as long as you've done
it no matter what you may have set up
for when you retire your identity
continues to be professional football
player and the idea that you have to
stop playing professional football while
you still have 25 to 30 to 40 years of
productive life left where you can do
something you just can't do that it's
got to be tough it's got to be tough uh
it's got to be agonizing it's got it's
got to be the kind of thing that just
makes you uh stick to your stomach all
day long so he wants to get back and
play he doesn't want the saints to come
to the conclusion they don't need him
and uh and i can understand it
completely nick foles day-to-day with a
hip gluteus injury far less serious than
it looked when he was just kind of
laying there motionless on monday night
after he hit the ground hard late in the
loss to the vikings and ultimately was
carted off i thought he wouldn't be back
all year he may be back for week 12
sunday night football against the green
bay packers because they're on a buy
this week yeah well and then like they
might really need him right too because
we don't where's mitchell trubisky at
and his you know injury and where he's
at there and then they'd have to rely on
tyler bray who we saw at the end of the
game who you know hasn't really played
nfl football so that would be scary
i'm glad to hear that about nick foles i
really am i mean it seems more like
anything he fell hard on that that right
back you know hip butt all that area and
then that way he kind of bent backwards
i was just watching it again last night
on a highlight show where man it just it
looks like he almost like spasmed as i
watched him there laying like it all
locked up you know like in some funny
movie where you see the old guys like
back lock up and he can't move i mean
that's really what it kind of looked
like just from a quarterback standpoint
the one thing i'll say it looked like it
was right it's right hip right butt for
a righty quarterback that's your push
leg i would say that's better than
having it on your left leg where the leg
you have to turn and twist into to where
that might make it a little easier for
him to get back and get going too but
glad it's not serious for nick foles
i used to say about jeff george he had
armed by nasa embodied by lego
i don't know that nick foles has armed
by nasa but he definitely has body by
lego and i think that's why and and
that's i i have
tremendous respect for him standing in
there and taking the abuse he does that
is a long lanky human being who is going
to get injured you just have to accept
it it's going to happen he doesn't have
that thick build he doesn't have that
instinct for avoiding contact or falling
in a way
or absorbing contact in a way that
minimizes nor does he have an offensive
line or a pass protection plan
that makes it even more brave right to
stand in there because he knows it's
coming drew locke a potential franchise
quarterback but at the same time
he can't stay healthy and i don't want
to say much about the situation because
the broncos in my mind are done they're
done it's over the question is after
this season what happens is lock the guy
for next year does vic fangio stay and
at what point at what point if ever does
the spotlight of accountability shine on
the guy who keeps hiring
coaches and finding quarterbacks that
aren't allowing the broncos to break
this cycle of losing chris yeah no i i
hear you mike and uh this is an
important time for drew locke you know
drew lock we hit on it a little
yesterday i believe but he's got talent
he really does you know his arm is
special he's a good athlete all those
things but yeah health has been an issue
and decision making has been an issue
way too aggres really these go hand in
hand too because
he holds the ball too long consistently
waiting for big plays he's got to learn
to live to fight another play live to
fight another day get the ball out of
your hands that every throw has to be a
25 yard completion and within that
you'll play better quarterbacking let
alone you won't get hit as much
you know he's taking too many big shots
too because he's always looking for the
big throw and he stands in there and i
give him a lot of credit but he's
beating himself up and then a lot of the
times yeah you're giving you credit for
standing in there but the guy's not open
so don't stand in there anymore check it
down get it out he's really got to learn
that aspect it's a little polished to
his game certainly needs is needed and
that's why i don't want him to miss time
he needs to play the end of the season
here he needs it so they can evaluate
him and he needs it to get better
himself
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports